love the idea of being here and it's the
way i've always voted in the past
whatever state i was living in at the
time so to me this is
this is the go-to you know i'm actually
hands-on
i'm here i'm part of the group instead
of just sending something in the mail
i'm around a bunch of other voters
and to hear the collapse when it's a
first-time voter those are amazing
things
so i'm very pleased with the way the
election has been going so far that's
great how long have you wait
just now um half an hour that's great
yeah now is the time before everyone
gets off work i think
yeah i know i think so too how important
is it i mean for everyone to get out
today and use their voice no matter how
they're doing it
it's a hard one because you know this
happens a lot
you know in politics however this year
is an exception to anything i've ever
seen
making it more important for everyone to
do their due diligence
and if six months from now they don't
like what happened if they didn't vote
they don't get you know they can't say
anything it's like okay well you can't
complain if you didn't get out and vote
so
yeah what was your name nancy now what
was your last name markowitz can you
spell that
m-a-r-k-o-w-i-t-z and normal spelling of
nancy no n-a-n-c-c
i graduate i guess yeah thank you nancy
you're welcome congratulations